[Music]
on this friday night the lentz
some canadians will go to to get
vaccinated
and coming here where they're being
handed out like candy when grabbing a
jab means going
south of the border why didn't an
ontario nursing home devastated by
covid19
follow its own outbreak plan we want to
prevent this happening in any other home
a global news investigation disaster in
israel
the religious festival that became a
deadly stampede the canadian victims
and a family's anguish i couldn't move
his arm
so then i was like shaking him from
marine wake up rain wake up
a healthy husband taken by covid his
widow's regret
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
mara nasser good evening and thanks for
joining us
tonight we have some hopeful news though
we're still in the grips at the third
wave of covid19
there are signs public health measures
and vaccines are finally
bringing the numbers down daily case
counts across the country have dropped 7
percent
in the last week and the vaccination
campaign is about to pick up steam
starting next week pfizer will be
shipping over 2 million doses a week to
canada
through to the end of june that is more
than double the weekly doses we received
in april
and today the federal government
announced those shots will be coming
from kalamazoo michigan instead of
europe
canada faced disruptions in its vaccine
campaign earlier this year
after a slowdown at the belgian
production plant
johnson johnson's vaccine has not been
administered here in canada yet
and there's already a hiccup late today
health canada said it's holding off
on the distributing of these shots
because they contain an ingredient
made at a facility where a mistake was
made and 15 million doses had to be
dumped
the j j doses will be released when
health canada is sure
they're safe and effective right now
over 32 percent of canadians have
received at least
one vaccine dose that's more than 12
million people
but only 2.9 percent of canadians are
fully vaccinated with two shots
still some canadians frustrated with
this rollout are tired of waiting
and they're finding the vaccine
elsewhere even if it takes them out of
the country
robin gill has our top story tonight
most canadians wouldn't know where
muncie indiana is
but alyssa johnston grew up here and
three weeks ago she left toronto for her
hometown
to get vaccinated she just received her
second dose
it was a little shocking coming from
canada where it's almost like the hunger
games and trying to find a vaccine
and coming here where they're being
handed out like candy three years ago
natasha freitas and her family
immigrated to canada
when they found they could get the shot
in ohio they hit the road
now they're hanging out in the catskills
mountains waiting for dose two
part of our motivation was the health
care system in canada so it's been
really
somewhat ironic to be in this situation
where we're going to the states for
healthcare
many states in the u.s are dropping
their residency requirement
and there are no lineups so anyone can
walk into an american pharmacy
and get a shot this immigration lawyer
based in washington state says
it's a new era of medical tourism it's
no different than if you're coming down
for elective surgery
and you want to pay for it but the
second in command at canada's public
health agency is toeing the line
and asking canadians to respect travel
restrictions
you know stay at home wait your turn and
i think uh certainly uh the doses are
coming
but canada's rollout has been slow
there's the wait for the first vaccine
there's also the four-month delay for
the second dose
natasha freitas does feel conflicted
that she's able to do this
it's great for me but not it doesn't
feel
as good as it would if everybody were
vaccinated
same goes for alyssa johnston it's one
more vaccine available to a canadian
up in toronto who needs it i'm not
taking you know a vaccine that i don't
need to take in canada they avoided the
long lineups
but they're still the two-week
quarantine when they get back
but they believe it's worth it robin
gill global news vancouver
and the reason the u.s is able to offer
canadians vaccines is because
it has too much supply and not enough
demand
a little later on global national we're
going to look at some of the creative
tactics being used to
encourage americans to get their shot
ontario premier doug ford is pushing the
federal government for more restrictions
on canada's land border with the united
states
he blames travelers for bringing in
contagious new variants
and says some are exploiting loopholes
in federal border measures
we will never get ahead of this virus
if we can't keep these deadly new
variants out of our country the borders
land in air their federal jurisdiction
and i assure you if i had the power i
would close down
pearson airport immediately i would shut
down the land border crossings
to only those who are absolutely
essential
new variants are still putting pressure
on ontario hospitals
the province is now getting help from
the military and as eric sorensen
reports there are some promising signs
the third wave is cresting the military
has moved into the temporary field
hospital outside sunnybrook hospital
a sign of the stress in toronto's health
care system and a demonstration of 34
eager recruits from joint task force
central ready to help
when a task such as this comes up when
we have the opportunity to provide
support and help
my team is very excited so pandemic no
pandemic when we have a chance to help
fellow canadians we're all in
a few patients have been transferred
here none seriously ill
doctors say they will receive the same
top-notch care the care
that we're providing inside the mobile
health unit would does not look any
different than the care people would
receive
in a bricks-and-mortar hospital it's the
latest response to a wave of coveted
cases yesterday toronto's michael garan
hospital had to transfer 10 patients to
other hospitals
because of a looming shortage of oxygen
five of them transported by orange the
province's air ambulance service
but there are signs of improvement in
ontario two weeks ago the outlook was
alarming
from over 700 cases and icu's modeling
foresaw
well over a thousand cases in may with
strong or moderate lockdown measures
possibly as high as fifteen hundred
today the number of covet cases and icus
is 883
but that is down from yesterday as
numbers are leveling off
and projections now see icu cases
falling during may
even though the new numbers might be
coming down
the load on the icu the load on
inpatient
hospital care is going to be felt for
weeks and months to come
meantime recent polls show
dissatisfaction with the ontario
premier's handling of the third wave
ontario only recently agreed to pay for
three sick days but his own science
table was blunt on whether it's enough
to stop the spread of covid variants
no the premier is pinning blame on
ottawa saying it could do more to cover
sick days
and says essential workers are getting
sick in the first place from covet
variants because of ottawa's lacks
border restrictions the variants within
the workplace cynthia
are coming from the borders the system
is broken all i'm asking the federal
government
to stop the variants from coming in and
these are deadly variants
an end of the third wave may be coming
into view but it can't come soon enough
for a premier whose political fortunes
have been engulfed by it
erik sorensen global news toronto
the prime minister rebuffed ontario's
request to strengthen measures at our
land borders
trudeau says there is a fundamental
difference between someone arriving by
air versus someone arriving by land
anyone who comes to the u.s land border
has already been tested
in the u.s in the last three days
then they have to get tested again and
everyone has to quarantine for two weeks
and do another test on day eight
we're enforcing very severe consequences
for anyone breaking these rules
ontario's long-term care coveted 19
commission
has just released a lengthy report into
how the province failed these facilities
during the pandemic it blames the
province for not acting fast enough
despite multiple warnings about the
virus
plus a number of problems that long
existed before the pandemic like
underfunding
understaffing and poor infrastructure
and it caused the coronavirus to ravage
care homes
the commission also says ontario did not
learn from the sars outbreak in 2003
and even quote lost the will to
prioritize being prepared for a pandemic
that included not having enough ppe
because the province destroyed its
emergency stockpile
just two days ago ontario's auditor
general published her own scathing
findings
our investigative team has spent months
looking into what happened
inside those care homes including the
worst hit in ontario
tender care living in toronto 81
residents there died
and as carolyn jarvis reports families
are asking
how it was able to get so bad
tender care living center had a plan in
place in case of a coveted outbreak
it had been in writing since last spring
and was verified by toronto public
health
the plan was to use a vacant wing of the
fourth floor to isolate any residents
who tested positive
this personal support worker whose
identity we've agreed to protect
says they were briefed on the plan at
meetings they told us time and time
again
in case of anything the residents would
be moved to the fourth floor
documents obtained by global news state
tender care could set up the unit the
same day
but when coveted hit on december 4th the
plan
wasn't put into play what they were
doing and i was so upset
they were moving the residents from unit
to unit two weeks into the outbreak and
toronto public health intervened
issuing a rare order for the home to
separate positive and negative residents
but by this point 118 residents were
already infected
toronto health i believe should have
acted much more aggressively
as soon as they are aware of the
outbreak the company contracted to
manage tender care
extendicare one of the largest owners
and operators of long-term care homes in
canada
said staff were falling ill and they
didn't have the resources to open the
floor
it was pretty shocking to me that it was
possible
to seem so unprepared dr kate greenway
who responded to a call for help on
social media
says the home felt frenetic certainly
what i was ordering immediately was
oxygen and dexamethasone and then at
some point later in that that
shift you know one of the nurses just
said well we don't have any more
anywhere what oxygen they were out of
oxygen right
i sort of sit back i don't i don't
understand so without oxygen
and without dexamethasone to open up
those lungs yeah
no you're in trouble greenway was able
to get oxygen from the nearby hospital
tender care says the stress on the
health system in the region at the time
meant that delivery of supplies
additional staff and other support
was not immediate by the end of the
outbreak on february 1st
81 people were dead all but five
residents in the home of just over 200
people had been infected it's
essential that we talk about what we saw
because we want to prevent this
happening in any other home
carolyn jarvis global news toronto
ontario's premier said he'd put an iron
ring around long-term care homes to
protect residents from a second wave
that didn't happen tomorrow on the new
reality carolyn takes a deeper look at
who is accountable
that's saturday at seven right here on
global a day after launching another
independent review of harassment and
sexual misconduct in the military
prime minister justin trudeau
acknowledged the measures his government
has taken have been inadequate the
comments came as trudeau was asked
why his government is launching another
investigation just
six years after the deshaun report done
under the previous harper government
describe the culture within the military
as hostile
and endemic
survivors continue to feel that they are
not appropriately
supported continue to feel like the only
thing they can do
is either talk to the media or come
forward anonymously
and that is a failing of the entire
system
trudeau says his government will look to
make immediate changes
while former supreme court justice louis
arbor conducts her work
the toronto blue jays say they're
cutting all ties with hall of famer
roberto alamar
after a sexual misconduct investigation
the investigation was launched after an
industry employee came forward with an
allegation from 2014.
major league baseball says it reviewed
the findings and found
alamar had violated league policies he's
now been placed
on mlb's ineligible list and the blue
jays say they're taking down his banner
at the rogers center alamar said in a
statement today he's disappointed
surprised and upset
with the news it was a joyful
celebration that became a
mass tragedy coming up what went wrong
at a religious festival
in israel
45 people including at least two
canadians have been killed in a stampede
in israel
and a warning some of the story contains
disturbing images
tens of thousands of mostly
ultra-orthodox jews had gathered to
celebrate
lag ba omer it was the first mass
religious gathering held in israel since
the country eased its covet 19
restrictions witnesses say the stampede
started when a large number of people
tried to exit the festival through a
narrow tunnel-like passage
it's a difficult moment and it's going
to be a difficult next couple of days
members of montreal's jewish community
have confirmed the canadian victims
are 21 year old devi steinmetz as well
as well-known singer
shraga gestetner
a shot for a shot still ahead creative
paths to
covet immunity in the united states
the situation in india remains dire as
the country struggles to deal with a
surge in covet 19 cases
india set another global record today
recording more than 385 thousand new
confirmed cases
in the last 24 hours more than 3 400
people
have died daily deaths have nearly
tripled in the past three weeks
hospitals are still overwhelmed and they
are still struggling to deal with
oxygen shortages but india is now facing
a new problem
a lack of vaccines several indian states
have run out of doses forcing them to
shut down
mass vaccination centers the u.s
meantime is facing a much different
problem
it has lots of vaccine supply but not
enough demand
tens of thousands of vaccine
appointments are going unfilled across
the country
the number of doses administered each
day in the u.s is dropping
and as jackson proskow explains that's
forcing some states to get creative
to convince vaccine skeptics to get the
shot
i am here at our large-scale vaccination
clinic
and as you can see we have lots of empty
chairs for all the vaccine available to
americans
the supply of willing recipients is
starting to dwindle
this is going to be an uphill battle i
really kind of see us in this time
crunch of
trying to get people vaccinated before
we see some of these other variants
100 million people are now fully
vaccinated more than half the population
has received at least one shot
and yet the rate of inoculation has
slowed dramatically down 25
in the last week to an average 2.5
million doses per day
we have to get to that 75
80 percent of us fully vaccinated
and really get this thing under control
there's little room for error because
one quarter of americans say they're
vaccine hesitant and will not get the
shot
i do not plan on getting it unless i am
forced
to change the game states are getting
creative
in louisiana a shot for shots program is
making its way through bars
well the convenience is what spoke to me
most today the fact that it's literally
five feet away from me
i work late nights i've either just
never found the time or just been too
exhausted to go out
some nba teams are planning to offer
vaccines to fans during games
and mobile clinics are fanning out
across communities
to meet people where they are getting as
many americans
vaccinated as efficiently and equitably
as possible is our path to returning
to a more normal lifestyle the next 100
million shots will be much tougher to
administer
but no less important the u.s still
averages more than 50
000 new infections each day each of us
needs to look around
in our communities and our families and
our circle of friends
and ask people if they have a plan to
get vaccinated the hope is that trusted
local voices like doctors and pastors
can help convince skeptics as
communities do all they can to get shots
into arms
jackson prosko global news washington
and new real world data shows the
benefits of vaccination
a u.s cdc study found those who were
given two doses of either the pfizer
biontec or moderna vaccine
were 94 percent less likely to be
hospitalized than those
who were not vaccinated but the efficacy
dropped to just 64 percent
if they only had one shot researchers
found
no significant effectiveness for people
who were less than 14 days past their
first dose
highlighting that it takes time for the
vaccine benefits to kick in
the findings are consistent with vaccine
clinical trials
it's the only night i didn't say i love
you because i thought i would have the
very next day
but kovid killed her husband with no
warning
that's next
we end tonight with a story of just how
cruel
covid19 can be we often report on the
statistics of the virus
the numbers of cases and dead but behind
each number is a person a british
columbia woman who lost her
young healthy husband to covet 19 is
sharing her family's heartbreaking story
and as ahmad agahi reports she hopes her
tragedy will serve as a warning
to all canadians he poured everything he
poured everything
into being a father from all the
memories they've shared
[Music]
who would have known these tragic
haunting moments
would be the last i just said okay good
night
come on that's the only night that i
didn't say i love you
it's the only night i've said i love you
every single night prior to that
it's the only night i didn't say i love
you because i thought i would have the
very next day
her husband 46 year old reed hans who
was diagnosed with covid19
10 days prior had a fever a cough
it was more comfortable for him to sleep
on the couch that night
and that's where he would struggle to
take his last breath
i went over just to say good morning
and then i put my hand on his arm
put my hand on his arm it was cold
and then when i tried to move his arm i
couldn't move his arm
so that i was like shaking him i'm
reading wake up marie wake up
and then it wasn't until i moved his
eyelids back and then i saw that he was
unresponsive so then i called 9-1-1
what happened next was a blur she says
until it was time to speak to her
children
i said okay i have something to tell you
about dad and you know right away i
don't know who was it that said it but
he said
is he dead and i said yes you know my
older one he's ten
and he just he just collapsed and he
just starts crying
and i think my eight-year-old he was sad
but i don't think he knew what to do and
he started crying because his brother
was
crying and so as boys
do you want to come over and you want to
say goodbye you know it's
not scary daddy just looks like he's
sleeping and they both said yes
i said okay so i walk them over and he's
still there lying peacefully and
they come in and my little guy comes
over and he's just like bye dad i love
you
like that was it like that was okay my
older one and
if i'd known he was gonna reach out i
would have stopped it but like i didn't
know what he was gonna do and he went
over and he touched him just saying
goodbye and then
his hand wrench back because of course
he's cold and just he's not moving
and now i just like i don't know like i
just i don't know like i gave them the
right to say goodbye and i don't know if
that was the right thing to do
and they had called the province's
hotline but because
he did not feel tightness in his chest
read hands did not go to the hospital on
the night of april 14th
i'm getting there why didn't he go to
the hospital sooner why didn't i take
him here why didn't i do this
i didn't know i worked with
the symptoms that he had and what he was
telling me
i don't think anybody knows the real
true symptoms of covet especially with
the variant
a healthy man hence was active happy and
there was
nothing more he loved than spending time
with his family
kobe does not discriminate it's not just
the elderly and the sick
and the weak my husband is only 46 years
old
so everybody out there you think that
you're invincible you're not
what a brave woman you are melissa
speaking through your pain
to warn others that is global national
for this friday night
i'm farrah nasser tonight's your canada
is this
mallard at towfield park in leduc
alberta we love seeing your canada so
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks so much for watching robin gill
will be with you tomorrow
until next time please take care of
yourselves and each other